comes to order the ring supermarket you  have a controversial opinion on 30  drinks  well I the problem with Lord of rings  from here no disrespect there's a fly  drowning in your beer sorry my I did  what yeah and is there any chance like  because presumably no one's allowed to  come on and change that seminar I would  drink a beer that had apply it and enjoy  wrong with my finger yes the fly yeah  course well no flies anyway go on Lord  of the Rings  now continuity sorry Justin  [Applause]  you get to fly and put it back here  Oh  [Applause]  we  we're gonna be alright  [Laughter]  can we just keep the camera on battle  options where we just  it's like spring watch but it's just a  flower you beer you pay oh oh  [Applause]  rocket something no no you have to suck  harder that's two you suck  [Laughter]  [Applause]  oh we're never ready to hear what you  think about me  [Music]